in the last couple of days I've given
you my 2024 predictions for Star Trek
and Stargate but what about all the
other big shows we've been talking about
this year what do I predict for those
welcome to Sid your Sci-Fi TV and M J so
I would say there's five big shows
returning shows that I've been talking
about this year the orille Babylon 5
Battlestar Galactica Firefly and the
expanse so there are 15 sources that
were very gracious enough to be involved
in this little discussion and they have
each told me yes or no whether they
think these shows are going to return so
let's kick this straight off with the
Orville first of all I'm going to tell
you that 11 out of 15 of the people I
asked said that no they do not think the
oral is going to return in 2014 or even
be announced now we've talked about this
a lot and there has been a bit of a
roller
coaster sometimes it looked like the
oille was going to return and other
times it looked like it didn't for me I
am going to say that look it is still
possible that the Orville might return
for another season I still say as again
many of my sources have been telling me
for a while now that Seth McFarland will
probably not return for full season he's
so busy with other projects He may not
even write the series it would have to
basic Al give his Blessing to be taken
over by somebody else I think there are
several actors that might not return and
I actually think that it would be a
completely different sort of show if it
did come back I'm being told there are
people over at Disney that would
absolutely love for this to come back
and they really want to show that was a
bit more like the first couple of
Seasons with a little bit more humor but
right now I think too much time has gone
by I think it is probably more and more
likely with each month that goes by that
it will not actually return or
definitely at least not in
20124 so my prediction for the Orville
no we will not get any major news on it
in
2024 Babylon 5 is another show that was
basically announced two years ago before
we knew about the animated movie Jay
Michael shinski was talking about how
the CW had asked him to write a p for a
new series now since then CW has been
sold and I told you that Warner Brothers
were actually still very interested but
they were looking for a partner to
create the show with I've told you that
they have spoken to Apple Amazon and
several other of the big streaming
services trying to find somebody to team
up with to create a new Babylon 5 hard
reboot series I spoke to my sources and
actually 10 out of 15 said no they don't
think Babylon 5 will be announced in
2024 and furthermore they actually don't
think the reboot is going to happen the
general opinion in the industry seems to
be that actually there will be more
animated movies that did very well and
Warner Brothers really like the straight
to DVD model that they've been using for
Batman cartoons and stuff for the last
few years and it worked really well for
Babalon 5 the fans seem mostly to want
that sort of thing as well they want the
original actors to return they want the
original characters they don't
necessarily want a hard reboot and the
feeling generally again in the industry
is hard reboots generally don't work so
it would seem to me the Babylon 5 is on
the road to nowhere my prediction for
2024 is that it will not actually get
the reboot we would hoping for but we
will see more bambalan 5 in more
animated movies and I think we could
even potentially see one in 2024 there's
a couple of things I know about that
that I'm not at Liberty to repeat but
just put it this way I think it's quite
likely Battle Star Galactica now this is
one that we can say pretty certainly is
going to be returning and all my sources
agree actually this is probably going to
be in the studio filming in the next
couple of months we are going to be
getting a new series showrun by Sam ma
or at least Sam asmail is going to be in
charge but there probably will be
somebody else actually day-to-day show
running it they came pretty close to
this before the strikes um it was
actually only months away from filming
then over a year ago this was supposed
to be existing within Universe of Ronald
D Moore's um version of Battlestar
Galactica and actually was going to also
exist within the same universe as a
movie I mentioned the movie because
again me and my sources are pretty much
unanimously in agreement that the movie
will not be happening definitely not in
2024 and actually may be stuck in
development hell we think a movie is
possible maybe down the line but the
Feeling Again within the industry and
over at the studio involved is that we
really don't think there's an appetite
for a movie and a series so they
basically picked one and the series
seems to have won out that seems to be
the most likely thing we're going to see
in
2024 Firefly is something that I've
spoken to you again about a few times
this year and I've been able to
exclusively tell you that Nathan fillian
is actually in very tentative talks
about returning with the franchise that
this would be a series of potentially TV
movies that he would do this alongside
his work on the rookie and appearances
in you know straight cinema movies like
he's been doing but he's actually been
talking about this as something he would
love to do if it does happen happen
it'll be something that he would be very
heavily involved in the story side of
things he would come on as an executive
producer apparently he has loads of
ideas on what he would like to do with
the characters apparently he's already
spoken to Alan tudk and he would
actually return for the first movie we
don't know how that's going to work
because yeah Shish kabed but that would
be amazing if he did but what are my
sources think well they actually said it
was basically a 7 to8 split and even the
people that said yes think we could get
an announcement in 2024 we're a little
bit unsure this is very very early on
discussions about this possibility there
is something that exactly Nathan Filan
would love to do the studio believes
there's an appetite for it and the idea
of doing these straight to streaming
movies really does have legs that has a
possibility this would be something that
would maybe only be three or four movies
it would be really big events for that
streaming provider when they do it they
think there would be massive excitement
and it would do very very well if they
get to do it now there are a few issues
the Disney currently own the rights and
the conversation is with them Disney
aren't going to be doing this by the way
this would be something would appear on
the poock network in um cooperation with
universal if they can actually get the
funding and if they can get everyone to
agree this is something that I think
would be very very popular and I
actually think as a continuation again
it could be something that the fans
would go absolutely crazy for Firefly
was a series that was taken away from us
cruy by Fox way too soon and it just
feels right for a series of TV movies to
come back and end the story who knows
maybe then we could get some sort of
spin-off series and then we can actually
see an exploration of this universe that
Jos Weeden created now that would be
seriously exciting so I'm going to say
this is a definite maybe but what is my
personal prediction I think this is
something that could be announced in
2024 but I I do share my sources um
hesitation to actually stick my neck out
much further than that this is a very
complicated deal mainly because of
Disney and if it was going to happen H I
would be first in line to watch this on
whichever platform it appears on let's
just hope Nathan fillian gets his wish
and that we get our wish for five flight
to return finally the expanse now this
is a complicated little fell this is a
TV series it is currently owned by the
Alcon television group they own the
rights to the project the guys that
created it people like um HW Coast B and
Mark Fergus have already moved on to
other projects and we're hoping they're
going to move on to Stargate we believe
the actual original writers of the
novels Daniel Abraham and Ty Frank are
still hopeful of actually creating their
own production company and bringing the
expanse back but where will it go
because at the moment the distribution
and production rights are held by Amazon
and Amazon clearly don't want to do more
expanse or do they well I've been
telling you for about two years now
basically ever since season six ended
that there were ideas to do a Trilogy of
movies at first and Amazon genuinely did
consider that they decided no because B
they they didn't think they'd do the
books Justice they thought doing the
books Justice would just cost way too
much money to produce and they weren't
sure there was the appetite there the
game has come across since and done very
well and actually proven that there is
still an appetite for a show like the
expanse and other companies have shown
an interest to Alcon Alcon has been in
conversations I know for certain with
Warner Brothers and Apple both of those
companies were interested in doing maybe
a spin-off series something that would
actually exist between book six and
seven because there was a 25 or 30 year
gap between the two books so they felt
that there was lots of the the universe
to explore now I have been a to tell
that Warner Brothers interest has waned
over time basically they've got enough
business issues to worry about in the
next 12 months and the expanse really is
something maybe they didn't want to
pursue but Apple apparently are still
interested so Alcon went to Amazon and
said look you don't want to do anything
with the expanse Apple does we'd like
permission to speak to them please and
apparently a couple about about a month
ago Amazon came back with the answer of
Alo hold on hold your horses we might
actually do something with the yet this
threw Alon completely a curveball they
did not expect Amazon to come back with
that response so where are we at right
now well Alcon does doesn't know but the
expanse is pretty much alcon's biggest
thing it owns it's a TV show that it
desperately needs back on screens
because basically it's its most valuable
asset and until it can get it back on
the screens it really doesn't have much
else so they are desperate to strike a
deal with somebody Amazon apparently
have about eight or nine months left on
their current contract with Alcon where
they have to make a decision by the end
of time period the rights revert back to
Alcon and Alcon can do whatever they
want with it but if Amison decides to do
something they can and Alcon can't do a
damn thing about it so fingers crossed
let's see what the next eight to nine
months hold what do we predict well my
sources are 14 out of 15 saying that yes
we believe there will be some sort of
announcement this year about a new
expanse project and I tend to agree with
them because I think by late summer the
rights revert back to Alcon and they
will strike a deal with somebody and
that will be a deal that they will
announce very quickly Daniel Abrams and
Ty Frank are desperate for this Narin
Shankar who's the showrunner apparently
is very interested in partnering with
them to create a new production company
that would in partnership with Alcon and
make the show and there are companies
like apple out there that are willing to
Splash the cash for me this is a show
that fits Apple perfectly
it just the tone of the show Etc would
fit it it's not a massively expensive
show to make and that's the type of
thing Alcon like to do if you think
about the foundation that is a show that
fits Apple perfectly and to be honest
the expanse is a very similar show in
style and tone The Silo again is a show
that fits perfectly with apple not
massively expensive to make but actually
they seem to have a knack of really
getting every dollar on the screen and
the expanse was the same if Apple were
to get their hands on this project late
summer I think we'd get an announcement
and I think something would probably be
on our screens by 2025 so that is my
prediction at some point this year we
will get an announcement on new expans I
don't think Amazon are going to take up
this option I think they're maybe
considering it but I think in the long
run I don't think they will I think
there's other things they want to do but
I think somebody like apple would so
there we go the orille no probably not
Babylon 5 no probably not Battle Star
Galactica series yes movie no probably
not Firefly maybe but it's complicated
and the expanse we're pretty confident
we'll hear something this year so those
are my predictions for 2024 but guys get
into the comments and tell me what
you're predicting do you think any of
these projects will get the green light
and actually if you had to pick one what
would it be get to the comments and tell
me exactly what you're thinking if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out you'll never miss
any of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com citre where most of our new
videos do Premiere first and you'd get
to see them without the adverts also go
to c.o. which is our dedicated website
and we do stories based on most of our
videos we try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest so go over
and check that out to as always please
stay safe happy New Year and I'll see
you
soon
[Music]